I'm Batman so hey everybody huh
I have you been using the excuse for the
past one week two weeks to not talk
about the Robert Pattinson his Batman
thing because it wasn't official it was
likely I acknowledged that but it wasn't
officially confirmed by Warner Brothers
by the people making the movie so I use
that as an excuse to not to have to
neither talk nor think about it well
it's it's official now so yeah let's
actually talk about this and like just a
briefly like to defend my putting it off
yeah part of it was laziness but also
like everyone else seems to forget this
but I remember when it was unofficially
confirmed that Joaquin Phoenix was gonna
be Doctor Strange and that didn't happen
either I mean it's stuff like that
that's why I usually wait for the
official confirmations and almost never
devote videos to rumor I don't like
things ending up being that outdated
wouldn't turned out not to be true but
in any case why do I have the kind of
integrity on a site this small I really
should just be going all out and going
for the clicks and just talking about
rumors as soon as they hit why do I have
integrity it's hurting my growth like
seriously anyways so Robert Pattinson
it's gotta be Batman okay like I'm
people are freaking out as they tend
like I can only think of one time that
we ever had casting for Batman that
didn't seem to tick off most fans and
that was Christian Bale and I honestly
think the only reason that people
weren't like if he hadn't had American
Psycho under his belt I think it would
have been just as much about they would
be like the guy from Newsies just like
they're going right now the guy from
Twilight like
come on he's an actor most actors have a
chunk of their resume that is
embarrassing and the difference is
Robert Pattinson 'he's biggest hit
happened to be the embarrassing thing
and if you don't think he's personally
embarrassed by those movies just seek
out some of the interviews he's given or
listen to some of the commentary tracks
that he's on he does not think very
highly of those movies he was obviously
in that the same reason Kristen Stewart
was cuz because his agent told him who's
gonna be a really good idea and they
were right but anyway I don't want this
to become a thing about Twilight
Twilight wrapped up long enough ago that
honestly people should be able to let it
go and it like as much as Twilight
wasn't good cuz it wasn't it was not the
end of pop culture and it didn't really
leave much of a lasting stain on the
culture as much as the detractors would
like to say I get it for people like who
have been into vampires way before
Twilight that that felt like like a real
dirtying of their fan like I have fans
who are like we're really into Anne Rice
or the original Dracula and like our or
you know any people are vampire the
masquerade or what-have-you maybe took
that stuff a little too seriously like
but I get where if that's your monster
of choice seeing something like Twilight
happen could take you off but unless
you're that specifically people got way
too worked up about that and honestly I
think in terms of his previous resume
prior to taking on the role of Batman I
think the closest comparison for
somebody who's already played Batman to
robber patents they get is Christian
Bale like the only difference is Patton
had it and Pattinson had a much bigger
like series but other than that pretty
boy young actor has spent most of his
adult career in smaller some smaller
indie ish films that get decent critical
reviews and aren't particularly well
seen I mean that was Christian Bale
prior to becoming Batman for the most
part and as far as how well who play the
role I mean my main concern is just
gonna be the accent
and that's just assuming they get him
working with the right dialect coach I'm
not even that worried about it so like
what are the actual qualifications to
play Batman and play decently honestly
having a good script in a decent
director I would argue that none of the
actors who have played Batman none of
them were inherently bad or wrong for
the part some of them were in projects
that were doing a kind of Batman or a
take on Batman orchid very confused take
on Batman that at their ground level
we're not going to work and who played
them wasn't gonna save it
I think that's happened more than a few
times I think Val Kilmer is a pretty
decent Batman all things considered I
think George Clooney is well he's not
the problem with that movie let's put it
that way I think Ben Affleck Wow in
Batman V Superman he was one of the few
things that almost worked and then in
Justice League they just retooled the
character from what he was cast to do so
much that he felt out of place but again
the problems like Batman working is
going to depend so much on the writing
and the directing I would say much more
so than a lot of other superheroes so
like you can have you can build
something out of a great central
performance on Superman on Iron Man
absolutely I mean Robert Downey jr. you
built that entire thing on that
performance but the thing is and like
Batman fans please don't at me more
often than not Batman's the least
interesting thing in his his own stories
and that's been especially true on film
so in order to get a decent Batman movie
it doesn't make or break on who you cast
as Batman or here's another way to put
it there's been to my way of thinking no
Batman movie that was good except for
the guy playing Batman the
movies that aren't good are not good for
a litany of reasons and maybe also
didn't have a Batman that really worked
but I've never seen a movie or was like
that was a good Batman movie but they
didn't quite cast that central part
right so getting overly hung up on
Robert Pattinson playing him to me he
just strikes as a misallocation of your
concern and this is not me saying
there's no reason to be concerned I got
plenty of reason to be concerned mainly
because I you know Warner Brothers in
terms of their handling of DC I'm
waiting for their track record to
improve steadily because Wonder Woman
was good Aquaman was fun I actually like
Justice League a lot better than a whole
lot of people did but it was also kind
of a mess
so like yeah but I've seen things going
in the direction where they're gonna be
or they could be better getting games
done in Suicide Squad to Wonder Woman -
they got patty Jenkins back for that you
know I I'm seeing things heading in the
direction where this could work but I
need to see the trajectory continue and
until it does I'm going to continue to
be any to be skeptical of anything that
Warner Brothers has its hands in because
Warner Brothers is a meddling studio so
my big questions on this are still
what's the story what's the tone and
that second one might actually be the
biggest thing for me because Batman has
been around long enough and has enough
facets to him both as a character and in
terms of his rogues guy because which
villains you pit him against is gonna
drastically shift the tone of the film
that you have a lot of leeway that you
could go action that you could go horror
tinged that you could go mystery that
you could go Noir there's a lot of
directions and tones that you could
adopt and that's kind of what I really
want to get a good sense of Pattinson
himself I think is a he's a decent
enough actor that he'll slot into most
of those things
I don't know how good he'd be in an
action scene but Batman an action scene
is in the full costume it's just gonna
be the stunt guy anyways what Pattinson
or anyone playing Batman playing Bruce
Wayne has to be able to convey is a
sense of intelligence a sense of
complexity a sense of duality because
that's what the best Batman portrayals
have provided and for me for the record
in case anybody like is wondering the
best live-action Batman for me is still
been Michael Keaton the best Batman
overall still Kevin Conroy
like that second one shouldn't really be
up for debate but in any case even with
hiccups and issues with the other Batman
portrayals for the most part some of
them still do something pretty well
somewhere along the line and again I
don't because Batman especially like wit
and again this is rumor with the rumor
that this is going to be a very loaded
cast like a lot of villains like to the
point that there's that you know people
have wondered is this based off the
Arkham Asylum games or what-have-you
which I doubt but you know there's a
rumor of a very long list of villains
making some kind of appearance in this
and that's just kind of emphasized
further the fact that Batman tends to be
the least interesting character and
these in these films especially but I
think honestly even in the comics more
often than not Batman is not the most
interesting thing he can be on occasion
but that's the minority of stories at
least in my own personal opinion like
Dark Knight Returns Batman is really
interesting
battening year one he's really
interesting but most of them like I love
no man's land he's not the most
interesting thing going on in it I love
the long Halloween he's not the most
interesting thing going on in it and you
know who they get to be the jaw line
I think Robert Pattinson has a solid
jawline he will be a perfectly
serviceable jawline I have probably
spent maybe three minutes total of what
will probably end up being what a 13
minute video or whatever actually
talking about Robert Pattinson I don't
know this is why I avoided talking about
him up to this point I don't find the
casting that interesting one or the
other I don't think it's a reason to
sound the alarm nor do I things like oh
that sounds really good
so oh wait and see which is kind of just
my holding pattern with the Warner
Brothers DC movies right now I they some
of them have been better lately I want
them to keep getting better but they
haven't earned my trust yet so I'm in a
wait-and-see pattern same thing with
this casting but it's official so I'm
finally open to talking about it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there is a
whole bunch of stuff to do because
there's buttons links patreon rewards
for supporting me also you help make
this show better and you know social
media my book etc etc etc links are all
down in the description give them a
click or don't you don't have to because
at the end of the day folks you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]